but we begin here this morning with the  sudden collapse of a Sea Cliff in  Southern California that has now claimed  at least three lives tons of debris fell  on beachgoers yesterday in Encinitas  north of San Diego a 30-foot long slab  of dense sandstone broke away and  plunged downward witnesses say first  responders had to dig people out of the  debris one woman died at the scene  two other adults died at the hospital  two more are hurt the collapse  apparently was caused by coastal erosion  which is a growing problem along the  California coast when high tide comes  it's just like there's nowhere to go  except for the cliff this morning the  cliff is described as unstable but  nearby homes are not said to be in  immediate danger